es un récord histórico los precios del
gas en europa alcanzaron los
345 euros por megavatio/hora el lunes
este aumento no fue una sorpresa luego
de que eeuu y sus aliados
anunciaron la posibilidad de un embargo
al gas y al petróleo rusos europa
importa el 40 por ciento de su gas desde
moscú por lo que cortar este flujo
podría tener un efecto devastador en el
continente
si se termina tomando esa decisión el
próximo invierno europa podría tener
escasez de gas
para algunos estados miembros de la
unión europea al 75% del gas llega de
rusia para alemania el gas ruso supone
más del 50% del suministro en francia
las importaciones suponen un 20 por
ciento con el fin de alejar a europa de
rusia el continente podría confiar más
en el gas noruego el segundo proveedor
para europa pero el país ya está
operando a su máxima capacidad el gas
noruego no sería suficiente para
reemplazar el suministro ruso otra
opción sobre la mesa es importar gas
natural licuado desde eeuu o qatar pero
los expertos afirman que transportarlo
sería complicado logísticamente y las
importaciones no serían suficientes para
completar las necesidades europeas lo
mismo pasa con el petróleo cerca de 25
millones de barriles se envían a europa
desde rusia cada día sumando un total
del 27 por ciento de su stock europa
podría compensar el impacto de las
sanciones librando más barriles de sus
reservas como pasó en junio del año
pasado cuando estados miembros de la
unión europea liberaron
825 millones de barriles de las reservas
de emergencia pero no está claro si
sería suficiente el bloque también
podría aumentar importaciones de otros
países en 2019 europa en puerto petróleo
de otras 12 naciones incluidas e irak o
nigeria cortar el suministro de petróleo
ruso sería un golpe duro para moscú los
réditos del petróleo son mucho mayores
para la economía rusa que los que aporta
al gas